to present the award for Best Supporting
Actress we have last year's Oscar winner
for Best Performance by a supporting
actor a man who got ahead in this
business by shamelessly trading on his
talent Walter Matthau
hey Bob how come everybody else comes
out here with a girl and I come out
alone
well I'm sure Walter when you announced
the winner she'd be so happy she'll
throw her arms around you and kiss you
with my luck she'll probably just cry a
lot well meet me backstage we'll both
rinse out a few things huh okay Bob the
five nominees for Best Performance by an
actress in a supporting role are Estelle
Parsons and Bonnie implied Carol
Channing in Thoroughly Modern Millie
Mildred network in barefoot in the park
bare Richards in guess who's coming to
dinner
Katherine Ross in the graduate
the winner is Estelle Parsons and money
in flight
I have to thank David Merrick who let me
out of my Broadway play the seven
dissents of Myrtle so I could be here
this evening and Lula tea now it
wouldn't really mean to me I also of
course want to express my great
gratitude to Arthur Penn my own
particular genius for really showing me
acting with something very special and
of course two Warren Beatty and thank
you all great moment
you